- Who would wear this?
My uncle.
(smooth, happy music)
- Aw, this smells like my dad.
- That smells like my dad.
- Like soap, and sea water.
- Sort of tropical, but,
like musky, like an older person.
- This reminds me of a guy wearing
a button-up blue shirt, where
it's like not offensive,
but there's nothing really
individual about it.
- The kind of men that wear
this are the kind of men
that think that women
that they meet in the bar
are going to have sex with them.
- Yeah, I don't know if I'd date him,
but I'd be their friend.
Smells like an old man.
Like spicy man.
- Oh, that smells like my dad, too.
- This is a man who
will have sex with you,
and you will like it.
- I picture someone from like
The Godfather.
- This is a little too acidic.
I'm looking for something
a little more grounded,
in a man, and in cologne.
- Douchebag.
Bro tool.
My ex-boyfriend.
- This is like the smell
that lingers after that weird guy
at the bar that's talking
to you finally leaves.
- I was trying to dance at the club,
and this guy, whoever's wearing this,
is trying to like feel my butt.
- This guy probably doesn't
know anything interesting,
because he's been working really hard
on getiing the perfect
five o'clock shadow.
- A buff man, with a soft side
to him, so like a fuzzy bear.
- This is a boy.
This is not a man.
A boy wears this.
This the same guy who's
wearing (beep) Axe.
- I totally dig this guy.
I might like, have sex with this guy.
- Okay, this is a douchebag
that turned into a dad.
- He smells like he would be handsome,
like a handsome prince,
who owns his own house,
and Lamborghini.
- Musky, but in not
like an unpleasant way.
- The guy that wears
this perfume is hoping
to be rugged and elegant at the same time,
not realizing that that
doesn't actually exist..
- Yeah, but how do I get
this out of the bottle,
and onto my skin?
- It's sweet as hell,
it's like a candy.
- I don't want my guy to
smell like what my hair
would smell like, it would
confuse me, sexually.
- This is something that
my future lover will wear.
- Aw, I'd really marry this guy.
- I think the sensitive
bro's wearing this.
This is the guy that'll like
take you out for dinner,
and talk about his
family, and his feelings,
but really he's only
thinking about what kind
of panties you have on.
- Everyone should be wearing this.
You wear this, and you
just smell like success.
Isn't that weird?